you may have seen a few people test flex
seal on a bucket say it Phil say it
that's a lot of damage
Oh pop it a little more okay
[Music]
Wow Phil that looks like a lot of damage
thank everybody that's right well I'm
making a video on flex tape that's right
I'm the first one to I've ever done so
thank you for recognizing the fact that
I'm coming up with new original ideas
what is he gonna do next
who knows not for real check out John
Trump's video he did a video on flex
tape it got a couple views I don't know
I don't count views anyway also John you
haven't uploaded in five months anyway
there's a few more flex tape videos to
review everybody her age so let's go
through them yeah that's what are you
gonna do wanna whatever day this comes
out now in case you're not familiar with
the the great word of the Flex tape let
me do a quick rundown there are these
really over-the-top commercials done
with the god of tape Phil himself and
just to give you an example I Phil Swift
here for flex tape the super strong
waterproof tape
Beckett instantly patch Vaughn ceiling
repair incredible right I want him to
slap my ass
just like he slapped that can then I
want him to seal my heart with Flex tape
flex tape is no ordinary tape
it's triple thick adhesive virtually
welds itself to the surface topping the
toughest leaks now they always do
something extremely over-the-top at the
end to sort of demonstrate how just how
powerful the flexed APIs in this one he
saws a boding hat to show you the power
of flex tape I saw this boat in half and
repaired it with only flex pays no way
that's going to work right not only this
flex tape powerful ease of hold the boat
together but it creates this super
strong watertight seal oh yeah well I
bet it's not even completely dry on the
inside the inside is completely dry well
now they introduce a new product called
flicks tape clear let's check it out
everybody
I feel Swift here for flex tape clear
the super strong waterproof tape that's
clearly the best way to patch bond
sealing repair what's tapes triple thick
adhesive instead yeah yeah okay but are
you gonna saw a boat in half or what
Phil I don't care unless you saw
something in half to show you the power
of flex paint clear
I coulda giant hole in another boat and
then they're bad with only flex tape
clear why don't we just clears oh my
gosh people the water out of the boat
oh yeah well I bet you he would not run
that boat over shark-infested waters but
even the shark-infested waters wide a
super strong watertight barrier that
seals out the elements and you could see
right through and you can see right
through when the shark attacks well Phil
you're a man man you're an absolute man
lad Jesus Christ oh how I wish I could
ride away the sunset would Phil just
prove the power of flex tape we seal the
ocean we seal the Pacific Ocean
everybody what is he gonna do next it's
there anything this man won't do to
demonstrate the power of the Flex tape
to show you the amazing sealing power
flex seal where we place the bottom of
this boat with the screen door and
covered it in flex seal why to show the
power of flex tape we put a door on a
boat just to show the power of flex tape
but it's the inside completely dry film
on the water not only does it stay
afloat but the inside is completely
dried fantastic fantastic absolutely
fantastic to show you the incredible
strength of flex shot over the place
huge holes through the bottom of that
boat with this giant cannon ready
why does this man hate boats
so much Phil please holy damage Wow
[Music]
black shot sealed every hole but not the
hole in my heart Phil not the hole in my
hair to show you the power of flex blue
which of all these parts and flex glued
them together and built the Flex monster
4x4 I spell this man why would I feel
Swift here 4 flex seal colors the
colorful way to coat seal and stop leaks
fast flex seal colors have the same
sealing power as the original now in
vibrant colors that can transform and
protect virtually anything literally
anything your broken marriage your
decapitated arm your depression and flex
seal colors will fix any problem that
you have like seal colors thick liquid
dries to a watertight flexible
rubberized coating Phil you just made a
bowl you just made a bowl for no reason
how are you going to get your pasta out
now this the quick shot fills cracks and
holes stopping the toughest leaks while
remaining completely flexible I use flex
sealed Brown to seal up my behind and no
one can tell the difference now thanks
to flex sealed brown thank you it's
actually liquid rubber wait this is
liquid rubber that's it that's all
you're selling me sealing outdoor
decorative items oh my god Phil you
literally murdered a bird just to prove
a point you've taken it too far Phil
forget thin runny spray paints all right
sure flex seal spray whatever but I've
seen your boat gimmick Phil what else
can you do please please Wow me because
there's nothing that's going to WoW me
at this point to show you the incredible
strength of flex seal we took this old
pickup truck what are you seal colors
sure Phil what are you doing with the
car blue agrees it's the coolest sub
you've ever seen Oh
he made a submarine everybody on a flex
seal red blue and green it's the coolest
sub you've ever seen phenomenal well
then we want to know how did you flex
seal and how to use let's shot send in
your photos and you have a chance to win
the ultimate prize package wow I can win
the ultimate prize package what is that
they don't say is it a date would Phil
himself so they did this competition
where you submit while you're flexing
apparently someone did up their boat
someone's gonna submit their dead
grandma my grandma died I just sprayed
her bird flex seal and she's just like I
always remembered her my favorite flex
seal has to be the Christmas commercial
because they trying to sell the flex
seal as a as a Christmas gift to someone
Phil Swift here this holiday season
given the flex seal family of products
everyone loves flex seal now can spray
the are you and our incredible flex
seal liquid starts out super thick and
turns into a strong flexible rubber
everyone loves flexi oh I kind of want
to dip a human in flex seal I just want
to know what happens you know I feel
Swift here for blast-off the powerful
sprays that quickly melts ice to prove
the power of that blast-off we created
global warming with the blast-off just a
quick blast milk snow and ice fast even
this flimsy tissue stays bone-dry with
the power of blackout you made a piece
of cloth fail now what how am I supposed
to use the napkin
if you can't wipe off anything
innovation everybody Phil does it the
best you may have seen a few people test
flex seal on a bucket but you've never
seen anything like mine
Perceval no no I have not seen anyone
stabbed a bucket to prove the point of
flex seal I don't think that's the kind
of thing people just do out of curiosity
come down here look at this this is
awesome that's not awesome that's a lot
of damage thank you guys thank you so
much let's flex seal everybody hooray
look like if you enjoyed this video hit
the button to subscribe videos every
single day
that's right I'll be here forever please
[Music]
I'll never stop running pretty city and
I'm never gonna fly tell me when it go
I'm like whenever I'm done with this
Pastor Mike the Edgar